a peptic ulcer is a sore that develops
in the lining of the lower part of your
esophagus for various parts of your
stomach
or small intestine
a peptic ulcer in your esophagus is
called an esophageal ulcer in your
stomach it is called a gastric ulcer
when the ulcer affects the first part of
your small intestine called the duodenum
it is called a duodenal ulcer when you
eat your stomach produces highly acidic
digestive juices also known as stomach
acid to help break down food then the
food passes into your duodenum for
further digestion and subsequent
absorption into the bloodstream to
protect your organs from the corrosive
effects of stomach acid a layer of mucus
coats the lining of your stomach and
duodenum when the protective mucus layer
breaks down stomach acid can seep into
the lining of your stomach or duodenum
and cause an ulcer most peptic ulcers
are caused by the bacteria Helicobacter
pylori also known as h pylori
scientists think these bacteria may
enter your body through contaminated
food or water or through close contact
with an infected person once inside your
body
they Lodge in the mucous layer of your
stomach or duodenum
as the bacteria grow they damage the
mucus layer allowing stomach acid to
reach the stomach or duodenum lining
together the bacteria and stomach acid
cause an ulcer some peptic ulcers are
linked to heavy usage of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs also known as
NSAIDs including aspirin and ibuprofen
these drugs reduce the ability of your
stomach and duodenum to protect
themselves from the effects of stomach
acid your doctor may prescribe one or a
combination of drugs to treat your
peptic ulcer if h pylori is the cause of
your ulcer you will take antibiotics to
kill the bacteria if your ulcer is due
to non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
your doctor will recommend you stop or
limit your use of these drugs for a
gastric ulcer you may be given a proton
pump inhibitor also known as a ppi to
decrease acid production in your stomach
for a duodenal ulcer you may be given a
histamine type 2 receptor antagonist
commonly known as an h2 blocker to
reduce the amount of acid secreted in
your stomach in addition your doctor may
recommend medications to coat and
protect the lining of your stomach and
duodenum until the ulcer has healed
these include sucrose 8 misoprostol and
bismuth subsalicylate commonly known as
pepto-bismol you may need surgery for an
ulcer that does not heal with medication
or you may need surgery for an ulcer
that goes away with treatment then comes
back
you may need an operation for an ulcer
that bleeds if your ulcer breaks through
or perforates the wall of your stomach
or duodenum you may need surgery to
repair the damage you may also need
surgery for an ulcer that blocks food
from moving out of your stomach if you
have one or more of these complications
your doctor may recommend one of the
following three surgical procedures a
vagotomy annan trek t'me or a pile or a
plasti in a vagotomy your surgeon will
cut part of your vagus nerve through
this nerve your brain tells your stomach
to release acid after your surgeon cuts
the nerve your stomach will secrete less
acid
in an ant recta me your surgeon will
remove the lower part of your stomach
which is called the Antrim the Antrim
signals your stomach to release acid
once it is removed your stomach releases
less acid if your ulcer is blocking the
exit of food from your stomach your
surgeon may perform a pie Lauro plasti
during this procedure your surgeon will
widen the pylorus which is the opening
between your stomach and duodenum
allowing food to pass through more
easily
while your ulcer heals you should avoid
alcohol and cigarettes as they can slow
the healing process and may make your
ulcer worse a few weeks after treatment
your doctor may perform an endoscopy
which is a procedure to look inside your
upper digestive tract to be sure your
ulcer has healed